we think of it as the land of plenty a
nation with boundless confidence and
optimism
[Music]
but something is happening in America
when you've seen in the past just the
natural disasters that have taken place
the world can change on a dime in the
home of the brave
is a sense of impending doom I feel
something's coming
and our whole families and groups of
people in the United States that are
just totally freaked out across this
vast superpower people are preparing for
the end of civilization the level of
fear and irrational fear in the u.s. is
certainly as high as it's ever been if
not higher ten percent of that radiation
is initial radiation which happens the
first minute of the blast and for those
who trade on fear business has never
been better
[Music]
I've reported from around the world on
countries coping with adversity in
America I've witnessed terrorist attacks
extreme weather civil unrest but I've
never felt society here is on the brink
of collapse
[Music]
and yet it seems an increasing number of
Americans do I want to find out why and
what they're doing to get ready I'm on
my way to a secret location in Kansas
[Music]
the middle of America it's where they
hid their nuclear warheads during the
Cold War in bases deep underground I've
come to visit one in very different
hands now okay we're a bunch of copies
and we'll hand them back you just stay
put for just a second
[Music]
have a good day I'm here to meet an
apocalyptic entrepreneur Larry Hall has
made a name selling to people with a lot
of money and a lot of fear he's turned a
missile base into a refuge for
millionaires we think Armageddon is
coming I want to see it through in style
see you've put in these big doors here
these are on there yeah these are 16,000
pounds each he's planned for everything
let's say that you're on your weight
here is an owner and there's a blockade
down the road and you can't get here we
could send one of these out to retrieve
you it's a pitbull VX heavily armored up
to 50 caliber armored vehicle we have
two of them interesting equipment it's a
doomsday hideaway straight out of a
James Bond film and Larry's going to
show me round
[Music]
from rural America to the suburbs there
are people afraid the world as we know
it is on the brink of falling apart
they call themselves Preppers because
they're preparing for the end
[Music]
and you got to be loud because you want
him to start in his backyard in Utah
Braxton's Southwick is prepping his 15
year old daughter for the days after
society's collapsed and looters have
come a roaring well we're training Riley
my daughter here on how to present her
weapon in case of intruder coming in
we're gonna use my son Colton here today
as the intruder usually intruder seeing
a weapon will stop if he doesn't she's
gonna draw on him and pull the trigger
to stop him
she's gonna try to get him to leave the
area without using any force and that's
really what we want to train our kids to
do yes all of our kids in Riley being
our last one prepping is basically being
ready and able to defend yourself
take care of yourself in case your
government or the world goes into
complete and total chaos
alright Colton come on in stop right
there okay good
hang on there son good you're showing
Authority you're loud you mean business
your hands are out there so even if he's
deaf he sees both hands he knows
something's going on alright
Colton keep coming stop right there or
I'll shoot good sorry there son now
seeing you draw the weapon okay he knows
you mean business your fingers off the
trigger that's good your Safety's on
it's gonna come up when it comes up the
safety comes off because you've already
told him twice third time it's done
right
go ahead alright stop right there he
made it this far really in the perfect
scenario I don't even want him this
close to you most American dads on
training their 15 $5 to to shoot the
intruder coming to the house why do you
think it's necessary uh we live in a
horrible world nowadays you know and
being a prepper in an end of a world
scenario I'm gone you know I'm something
happened to me I want my children to be
able to protect themselves and the home
it doesn't does it worry you right here
your dad saying that he might not
if the end of the world comes or
something terrible happens yeah that
does scare me that how are you a bit
yeah it does but I know that my brothers
and my older siblings will be there for
me and you and I can protect myself
that's right
that's why we do this there are some
folks and there are families and there
are people that are scared to death that
they believe that there is going to be a
catastrophe for me it was 9/11 when the
airplanes went into the towers in New
York
that was a turning point for me
because they shut phone service down in
our area for a long while we weren't
able to communicate with each other and
I remember at home that night just
saying to him like if we can't
communicate I need a plan we need to
have a plan in place how we can meet up
and how can we get back together and he
wrote it out and yeah we just taped it
in the word of our cabinet so that I
could open it quickly and read what I
needed to do
[Music]
so normal garage from the outside in the
13 years since 9/11 prepper Jay Blevins
has amassed a private armory but there
are a few things that probably stand out
to you as you walk in and yeah I do have
a couple of knives this is not normally
a self-defense weapon this is mostly for
hunting it's called an expandable baton
basically works like that it gives you
an extension you know should Armageddon
or whatever come to our doorstep I want
to feel that I can take care of my
family my friends and anybody who may
need help again if you use this against
somebody the likelihood of causing
severe injury or possibly death is
probably I so this is good for home
defense if you flip it over it's
actually got a shell carrier on the side
there I mean I'm only gonna use it if my
life is in danger and I feel like I need
to so they interviewed us for this one
as well Jay's a celebrity in the world
of Preppers
he writes manuals on surviving he speaks
at survival expose on the need to get
ready we organize these types of events
as well and I hear constantly people
saying I can't put my finger on it but
something's just not right
[Music]
fear is big business in the US the doom
boom has spawned an industry worth
millions
[Music]
hello fellow thrivers we've been out
visiting you in your neighborhoods
trying to thrive and being America a lot
of that money is spent on eating forget
survivalists foraging in the woods for
nuts and berries Preppers have their own
cuisine and cookery shows freeze-dried
lovers we have mashed potatoes in a food
plant in Utah chef Todd demonstrates the
wonders of dried food ideal for
surviving the apocalypse because it
lasts for years we'll see you next month
thank you
[Music]
once it comes through a can labeler its
thrive lives chief executive Jason budge
shows me behind the scenes just as a
bola fear is reaching fever pitch in
America anytime there's there are
certain situations in the economy and
these scares and disaster or disease
Ebola for example the demand spikes for
our product so the way with up through
the FO this guy you'll you're selling
more it's we're selling a little more
right now
yeah the demands going up and yeah
business is good we don't we don't like
to celebrate those moments but yeah
business is increasing right now
Jason isn't just making money out of
Preppers he's One himself we just felt
that if we were prepared we could always
take care of the needs of our family my
wife and I have five kids we always want
to be in a situation where they're there
they're safe and they're prepared I'm so
other Preppers who you are selling to
who are afraid of a terrorist attack or
a weather disaster or solar flare do you
think they'll crazy or do you think you
know you can you can relate to what
they're worried about Kenny I think
they're wise the water temperature is
maintained at about 84 degrees but no
one sells the doom boom quite like Larry
Hall
back in Kansas inside his underground
survival complex he's getting into his
stride so we've made it high-end so they
believe me the owners came in here we've
had two owners that came here and cried
when they saw it they literally cried it
was so far beyond their expectations
they were just enjoyed and working our
way up
so I started 15 stories underground and
we'll come back up right 200 feet deep
protected by walls of reinforced
concrete nine feet thick there are 12
floors of underground apartments and
luxury facilities
each survival condominium yours for just
three million dollars this is our
hydroponics and aquaculture area these
are for the crops carrots are different
and lettuce or kale or different three
different species of tilapia sitting on
the ground fish foam and normal foam
exactly here we've got the classroom of
the future each one of these has a an
apple computer at them
the teachers post is over here one month
you'll be the teacher one month I'll be
the teacher we've gone with the approach
of let's make this a fun place to be
regardless of why you're here so this is
a survival contact this is one of the
congos a three-bedroom two-bath unit
this is the dining area a curved wall is
the shape of the inside of the missile
silo there's a jacuzzi tub here the
toilets are interesting you can use them
in a bidet mode everything from the
water temperature to the spray patterns
plenty of room for all the stuff and
very normal
[Music]
and here we have the food storage room
this is my gun safe we have a lot of
stuff in here this is my tactical
shotgun they call them cookies and it's
an emergency food ration and we have
these in our 72-hour kit as well this is
my deer hunting rifle braixen Southwick
and his wife Cara of a basement to see
them through the apocalypse and then we
rotate through our bags you'll notice
that they're all marked with a date a
lot of sugar they're a lot of sugar
people like sugar 1,200 rounds of five
five six and a lot of salts as well I
think he's afraid of running out of
socks and duct tape very important of
course well they say you can fix
everything fix anything and everything
with duct tape they call themselves
Preppers like more and more Americans
determined to be prepared for the end of
the world America has a bunch of spoiled
people in it and when you take that away
from them they're gonna throw a fit and
they're gonna come after the people who
were prepared like myself and my friends
and other Preppers so every prepper has
a way to protect themselves every one of
them because they know that's exactly
what's going to happen we think we could
go six months to a year and not have to
buy anything what's in here with what's
in here and what if people know that
you've got all the food and they're
gonna come after you well then that's
why we've trained with our weapons the
whole country will turn into a big
schoolyard again with bullies and those
bullies are gonna be taking every
resource they can it's the reality of
our world and you want to see think that
that's gonna happen in your lifetime I
pray to God it doesn't but I think it is
cuz you're kind of turning your family
into an army a small army in a sense
honey I am and I'm trying to keep that
as normal as possible terrorism natural
disasters most families are unprepared
snoozle are breaking this afternoon
what kills inside the United States
living in America you'd be forgiven for
thinking the end is almost upon us
there is a case in Dallas County
even if plenty of people will tell you
we've never been safer so with the
apocalypse apparently fast approaching
I've come to the woods for a course on
the basics of prepping from survivalist
Dave Carlson you want to wet you want to
hold her an angle like this and just
kind of scrape it on there okay you're
taught how to make fire with flint and
steel and just a shoelace and bits of
wood it's a long painstaking process
there you go all right well when easy
got there in the end more and more
Americans are doing what I'm doing
learning how to survive in the wild
one of the first things they learn is
finding water somewhere along the line
people have found water back in here so
that gives you an indication that this
would be a good place to look however
unappealing I'm building somewhere to
shelter this is the size someone would
want if they were going to be here for
an extended period of time
after all that I asked Dave if he shares
his clients apocalyptic fears if you had
a large-scale disaster particularly if
it was a terrorist event I can see you
know I could see very bad things
happening because people do crazy stuff
when they're scared they do crazy stuff
when they're hungry like every month a
network of prepper families is meeting
in Jay and Holly Blevins is suburban
home in Virginia our network is pretty
much just a fancy name for our friends
who like that and family that you know
in an emergency we would you know kind
of pull together when we get together
like this we just typically do some sort
of training so today we have Tim McQuay
with us and he's gonna show us how to do
some primitive fire skills she's gonna
show us how we can start a fire and if
you spin the drill hard enough and fast
enough it actually creates a little
ember so that little spark is over a
thousand degrees Fahrenheit
we prepare for
anything that could happen anything from
bad weather to a dirty bomb or terrorist
attack anything like that I mean we have
we have posters out in the wilderness
that we can go to we have strongholds
that we can go to so if I'm in the city
working down DC or something and
something happens and the kids and a
wife are out here you know they can
rally together with the people that are
here you know until I can get out here
and that's pretty much the way the whole
group operates all right now you try
this seems to be something uniquely
American about prepping something to do
with the way only Americans have always
thought about life and its problems
Americans are fairly unique as world
citizens and that we tend to believe
that we control our own destiny as
individuals to a much greater extent
than we really do this has serious
ramifications on the plus side I mean
the achieve a lot as individuals on the
other hand where there are real dangers
to take an individualistic approach is
usually exactly the wrong thing to do so
the kinds of things that Preppers for
instance are preparing to protect
themselves from are much better hand
at a community-wide basis and they are
within your home and check in with the
Rangemaster
[Applause]
we could be out helping other people and
she be hot along the more time I spend
with Preppers the more I wonder what
it's doing to their families I joined
Braxton and his family on the shooting
range
putting the training into practice with
live ammunition I'm coming after she
can't
what did Riley make of being trained to
shoot post-apocalyptic looters so having
that feel right felt good it was kind of
scary but it was good was it scary cuz I
was just thinking what if it was a real
person and I really had to do that that
kind of felt real yeah was that my you
think it makes me hope that I'm not home
alone if something ever happens but it
makes me glad that I have the training
and I could take care of myself
whether or not it's good for the
children the south wakes do seem
genuinely afraid of what could be coming
but what about Larry selling his
survival condos for millions is he just
doing this for the money
because the people that people are
supposed to look at this and think well
the whole prepping industry has become
an industry and you presumably have made
a fair amount of money out of this and
in a sense what people like you were
doing is peddling fear and profiting
from it what do you say to people like
that
well again I don't think it's fear I
think it's awareness I think that fear
has a negative connotation I don't think
I'm peddling fear I think I'm peddling
preparedness and there's a big
difference Larry's sales pitch is you
can live through Armageddon and stay
normal so you can you could while away
the apocalypse watching films here well
you you will have certain amount of
downtime where you want to not be bored
and one of the obviously everyone spends
a lot of time probably too much time
watching TV but we've loaded thousands
of movies in here you know this is one
more thing that you can do to add some
normal seats here time off grid this is
the armory we can't go in there and film
but you might let us film in that no but
I was beginning to wonder what it would
be like
deep underground with Larry and his
millionaire clients you come in here
this is the holding cell the jail if you
will it's got the standard county lockup
where you've got the toilet and the sink
and the just like they do in the county
facility so it's gonna be full anyone
having a bad day these are people who
paid three million dollars for their
condos they want they that's a lock them
up well and just like in society you can
pay 50 million dollars for your house
and it doesn't give you the right to go
punch your neighbor in the nose does it
we can bring them in here
if doomsday comes this will be the view
and this place could be in demand from
hungry desperate people
it's called snipers poster now is that
yes is that for only got a sniper you
could go in that post we do so it's like
Fort Knox what are you expecting to
happen here well if there's day a bad
event like a dirty bomb and and people
are being told to flee cities and things
we could find ourselves under martial
law we can change the displays to show
us more information we have something of
interest in any particular camera like
this one this cows pretty interesting he
could be dressed up a person dressed up
as a cow we might want to zoom in on him
so we could change this whole display to
be this one display so far they've only
seen cows not Horsemen of the Apocalypse
but when the end does come Larry and the
hordes of American Preppers like him
reckon they'll be ready
you
you